calling page seven edgar samaniago
c350360
judge thank you for calling that the
spiral gotta for summer
and i believe he's in custody on video
okay
and for the state mr hammer for the
state hi mr hammer
all right mr regatta it is your motion
we're going to handle the or motion
first i did read through your motion
and i also read through the states
opposition as well as their attached
exhibits
um is there anything you wanted to add
at this time yes judge i know that you
went through the motion i know
looking at this case he's been in
custody
of or
and i know that we haven't had any
addressing of of the
issue about bell amount i believe there
is a bell amount of a million
but going under the valdez hemings uh
following the
the case that obviously judge there's
several issues and i think you've read
that
in my motion in which states he is
full-time
uh born and raised in las vegas uh he
had him
he has employment wait waiting with his
family business
and that varies from landscaping to
construction
to even his mom having a second-hand
store
and he has as people waiting for him to
work
the other issue his entire family is in
las vegas he's never had any failures to
appear
this is his first and only felony case
and i know it's
it's uh hitting the top of the the scale
of cases on felonies
but he has one dui prior i believe two
or three years ago
no other felonies he has not had any
other figure to appear
and i know with this amount just
speaking with the family and i have
direct contact with
uh almost all the family members have
contacted me regarding this
they can try to come together with some
money but obviously a million dollar
bail judge
is excessive to the point where it's not
even
somewhat achievable in any any any way
possible i know under the valdez hemings
case
we do uh have those factors that i i
went over with you
i'm asking for a bail amount and i know
with the fact
i've talked to the family and i know
that there is going to be argument
not to change anything on the bail or
even at some point maybe increase the
bill or
or put a no bail but at this point judge
these are allegations
i know uh there is some court date set
forward
he's been in custody uh for going on
close to a year uh wheat ass and i
after speaking with the they had
available
somewhere between 100 and be very frank
to the court 100
to 150 000 bill they can achieve
that 15 with the bail bond company and
they've had discussions with bail bond
companies
um anything beyond that is going to be
unachievable
uh even to the million dollar mark
obviously but that's why i brought this
motion
judge i know that we have um you know
serious charges against him he's he's
always been
uh you know in the community born and
raised here and like i said if if
anything if you want to put them on the
other
the bracelets a high level what not he
will
uh he will adhere to whatever the court
requirements would be
i'd submit it with that judge and ask
for a reduction of bail
is it correct that he's already had a
valdez james hearing in this case
i believe two different times i don't i
didn't see that in any
any of the notes that i've been given
from the public defender's office that's
why i was bringing that i didn't know it
was and when i talked to him he doesn't
believe
it was and i i think it was a million
which obviously
under now the feminist even with that i
mean he wouldn't it wouldn't be
achievable that's why i brought this
motion judge i was unaware of that
all right mr hamner um the court is
correct
and this is the third valdez james
hearing that has been before
the court uh two other judges have
examined this initially it was no bail
uh judge spyson said it at a million
dollars
when you look at these factors under
valdez jimenez the one million dollars
bail is appropriate
valve as an analysis makes it very clear
if there are people that are either
a danger to the community or there's a
risk that they may not come back to
court
it doesn't matter how much money you
have valdez jimenez clearly states
you can set an amount higher than they
can afford and this is a certainly a
candidate for the million dollar bail is
absolutely appropriate
this same family structure that is being
touted by the defense
when he picked up his dui case it was in
place when he was out of custody
on that case when he decided to shoot
officer michelonis in the head
and then go and shoot at other officers
subsequent to that
the bottom line is the family structure
should give this court absolutely no
comfort whatsoever
because it's been in place this entire
time he is an absolute dangerous
community you would think someone who is
pending serious dui charges would be
mining all their p's and q's
instead what he did was as recklessly
and as dangerously as i can think of
simply went downtown got a motel with
his girlfriend
and then just decided for fun to start
shooting at cops
when there there are hundreds of people
on las vegas boulevard
trying to exercise their first amendment
right to process he didn't just endanger
the lives of these police officers
but every other citizen who was out
there whether it was the travel lodge
guests
or just regular citizens on las vegas
boulevard so
at this point and you've seen the
evidence that was just presented at
preliminary hearing that's not even
everything that we have for trial the
evidence is overwhelming
the likely of conviction the likelihood
of conviction is extraordinarily high
and if he sets a low bail mountain and
he bails out
he's a huge flight risk i think he's
going to take off
i mean under these facts with that video
with the people who identified him
and all the evidence that he left behind
so at this point the motion
respectfully has not provided anything
to offer a changed circumstance to
reduce that bail
so respectfully asking to deny the
motion
all right first of all i do agree there
is some change in circumstance so that i
could consider this
um in that he is no longer has that
another open pending case that has been
resolved
um so i can consider the motion here the
state is seeking continued preventative
detention
as we all know the purpose of bail is
twofold to ensure that the defendant
returns to court and keep the community
safe
i think those are both an issue here and
it's serious issue
um he mr san diego does have these
community ties in a family in vegas as
well as a limited criminal history
bail factors weigh so heavily against
release including the
incredibly serious nature of these
charges he is facing and the extremely
high likelihood of
conviction based on the witness
testimony based on
the video testimony and ultimately in
reading the state's
motion i find that the facts of this
case are far worse than what i had
previously believed and what had
previously been put in the media
because there's that shooting of the
officers who were trying to assist their
fallen co-worker
um there's nothing that has been
presented to me here that was not
presented to the previous judges
i understand that this million dollar
bail does operate as a de facto
incarceration
but i do also find that there are no
non-monetary conditions that could keep
the community safe
or really ensure his return to court
based on
um the factors that i've laid out
initially at this point the motion is
denied
we do have the case on for a uh
pre-trial conference today mr ogata
i know that you are fairly new on this
case will you be able to go forward
in on a june setting no i spoke
with uh mr hamner in his office a couple
days ago
and he and i uh looked at that i will
not be
proceeding on the june 2nd if i can't
ask the court for the next setting
so uh am i correct that he is uninvoked
at this point
i i believe so judge he waited he waved
okay just making sure because i just
want to make sure that point so at this
point we aren't able to handle
um uninvoked or uninvoked defendants on
that calendar call
or on our june stacks so we would be
looking at either the september staff
that starts on september 7th and then
there's a five-week stack after that
or a november stack which works best for
the parties
i would ask for a november saying the
state would have been ready to go
in june but we're asking for a november
setting again
um i have a lot of murder cases and
given the change of reopening things up
i think
it's going to be very busy um for the
summer into the fall so november would
be
more ideal for our schedule okay perfect
that's what we'll do we'll do the
november stack which will be
a trial date of november 15
9 am calendar call november 9th
11 am thank you
all right anything further from either
party no judge
thank your honor thank you everyone
thank you judge
thank you thank you mr gotta thank you
mr hammer